за миття група молодих українців у
ардіті пустувати рекорд проривається
назовні територію через просто піхотний
dried 1 година на меншому полі
найбільшого скронь його полігону україна
суду ти частини проводять з брови до
бойової готовності ось точно церкви з
вдруге звичайно не українські там
риканський весь килим нас пильних
начальник живий він відкритий нижньої тато
кеш, що радує стиль, далі плутати я так за
6 місяців спецпідготовку пройдемо чекали
цода пишатися сюди через
malagasy
так ми його вигляд чого йому за короткий джаз
хлопці змінилася і стала до статечного
нижчим і спорту ванішем і віджим і на вч
а йому їх проти ти в групах поспішаю
шпильку
a supple його пари подача але хлопці
тут вже відкриті до нових знань до нас і
дати про що ми хочемо і їх навчить
а в голови і знову ці труби це
міжнародні на вч вони регулярно ми
обіцяють у клуні щільно дискових ризикові
реформи проте проходить та їх молити
малюка гвардійці вона вся кава з бронкс
та україни за поважалися кого експерт юрій
бутусів
when вже по на 20 руки до злити ж
проблеми армії повз план реформ у
україні
в них же по на дрік там з йдете і він їм
а я указ президента і 15 жовтня якийсь
передача я в ліс і не змін у програму
розвитку здвоєних сил України в
програму про скидання скинутих сил
україни того мічкова доктриною україни
ціни спрацьовано даси і девіна теж
бутусів пропаду я хлопець від і до sweet
подібних краєм собою гаррі це польша річки
модерні завала весь коза стандартам у на
ту
застриб кадомців краєм паршиво неприємний
підрозділ жарт врагово не україна
navlab створ це вже за пиво рапу то для
всі вкажи посагу стиснуті сіна
радикальних зради помінятися 100
управління вибраних сил україни з брови
силах і дві паралельні нам правді
ланки управління міністерства оборони
генштаб за нашим та законом їх положення
виписали q 2 паралельних відомств які
дублі youtube нині така система за
вишилася а usb a dog відра жіночих частина
iv але я краще яблуку я проведення
реформ а наяву нових вини не дозволяю про
гидко ух вольові рішення
влада more гуллемо ризиковий експорт
львова can статуя зорі kuga laser і
формування весь кобла вдома вас роботи
значно більша система
я здавалося б його на кол і сам
особливо змінити тут треба перш за все
не боялися кардинальних кадрів з ментів
ти не боятися
прошивати цих людей віку проявила себе
ж я патріот
ох рим кадрового про потрібно не завищується
фінансово харчування так у ставків терміну
армію ви робили на понад сімнадцять
миль яскравим рудим більше лише за кілька днів
вам декор ти практично всі прийшли треба
зброя не національна гвардія
фінансується краще одна горошина
аліментарний промови на вас то чаю і тут
якось, наприклад, на яворівському полігоні
розрізає зі своїх та чужих у край легко
ви і клина то всі коди
він в уніформі українець кіно завардувати їх
то в чому
вирізаєте обмундируванням позбавити їх то
ваивасвата
над вардити і їх урізав на жаль та не ходив
та волонтери
фінансована саваня тут треба вже
славська ми диби масть накаляй африці
приїхала сюди і кованого оружня не
я котячи нами і ми розуміємо а що нам їду
чого правда ще є почав працювати на
спину американського українську програм
анапчани уряд шви робити 19 мільйонів
доларів ще такий мат і дістати не
забувши печінки і в усьому українську
веселий вич і вають і на кухні і на
полігоні наприклад на шкірі нп гострий
солдату 3 травня але в ціль
з перебування наших скинутих сил
she is з формування
туди на захід і
чим роком тому з них наша приклад
армія стала ще гарнішою забуде їх розумів
ці солдати готові буран це свою
україну
проте чогось вований захист своїх
бо ж солдатів сотні з чіткою концепцією
реформи навіть хоч мій процес уже й
просто на клина ту нажаль con статуї
чакре митися україни поки що з рахунків
чеський на місці